- Hi guys, my name is Mimo
and I'm a co-owner producer here at Tasty.
My background is in pastries.
One of my favorite things
to bake are brownies.
Brownies are so great
because they're fudgy,
they're rich, they're chocolatey,
and that sweet place
between a cake and a cookie.
I know we're all busy,
and you might think you don't
have time to make dessert.
But today I wanna show you how to make
a four-minute, 40-minute
and four-hour brownie.
So let's do this.
Our first recipe is really easy
and comes together just in four minutes.
So first, I'm gonna add my
butter into my chocolate chip
and put this in the microwave
to melt everything together
for 30 seconds.
And now we just patiently wait.
And now I'm gonna dump my
melted chocolate into this bowl.
Then I'm gonna whisk my sugar and my egg.
This is just one of those recipes.
When you're watching a movie
and you crave a dessert
but you don't wanna put in the effort.
So you just go and whip it up really fast
with minimal ingredients.
And now I'm gonna sift my cocoa powder.
I like to sifting it because
I want it to be all smooth.
Then we're gonna use a rubber
spatula and mix it in there.
I love how shiny it is.
This is definitely gonna be fudgy.
And now for an extra
added chocolate flavor,
we're adding chocolate chips.
I picked semisweet chocolate
because it's the perfect bitterness
and doesn't add too much
sweetness to the dessert.
Our batters ready.
And now I have this
microwave-safe Pyrex dish.
I've greased it and lined
it with this parchment.
And now we're gonna
add the batter into it.
We're gonna use an offset
spatula to smooth it all out.
That way it's beautiful.
If you don't have an offset spatula,
feel free to use the back of a spoon.
Smoothing it out also helps
you brownie bake evenly.
I saved a little bit of
chocolate chip to sprinkle on top
just for a bit aesthetic.
It doesn't hurt to have
more chocolate, so go crazy.
That took about two
minutes to put together.
And now we're gonna put it in
the microwave for two minutes.
And now we patiently wait.
It smells so good, I think
are brownies all ready.
I'm gonna cut this in half.
But no judgement if you don't
wanna share with anybody,
you worked hard for four minutes,
so feel free to enjoy all by yourself.
Look at that.
Look at all that melted
chocolate fudgy the center.
And it's that simple four minutes
and you have a beautiful dessert.
And now let's taste this brownie.
Hmmm, this is so good.
And for something you made four minutes.
Oh my gosh, I don't think
you have to tell anybody
it was microwaved.
You can just tell 'em you
spent hours making this.
This is good, but I'm gonna
show you something even better.
So let's go make
our 40-minute brownie.
This is a pretty standard
recipe with minimal ingredients.
First we're gonna sift our
flour and cocoa powder.
I'm also gonna sift our baking powder.
I love sifting the dry ingredients
because it helps me not over mix my batter
and it creates a very smooth,
consistent batter for the brownie.
And now we're gonna give this
just a nice little whisk.
Then set your bowl aside
and we're gonna start
with the big bowl.
I'm gonna add my eggs and then
now I'm gonna add my sugar
and we will whisk this together.
This looks good.
And now I'm gonna slowly
add my hot butter.
The reason you wanna do it slowly
is you don't wanna scramble your eggs.
This is called tempering
and that is bringing everything
up to temperature slowly.
This is looking beautiful.
And now we're gonna
add our salt into this.
The reason I didn't mix my
salt with the dry ingredient
is 'cause the salt crystals are too big
and usually get stuck in this sector.
And now we're gonna
add our dry ingredients
and we're gonna use a rubber
spatula to fold it in.
And again we don't wanna over mix.
The reason is we're
looking for a fudgy brownie
and we don't want rubber.
Again, I'm turning my bowl
the opposite direction
as a fold it.
Now we're gonna add our
semisweet chocolate chip.
I like semisweet because
it's a perfect balance
between sweetness and bitterness.
I'm just not a sweet dessert person,
I like the perfect balance.
Our brownie batter looks beautiful.
And I have an eight-by-eight
baking pan here,
it's greased and lined with parchment.
Now we're gonna add our
batter into the pan.
What I love about this
recipe is it's so fudgy.
Again, we're gonna use an
offset spatula, my best friend,
to smooth it all out.
I'd make these brownies if I
want to make something special
but also feeling lazy at the same time.
So I think it would impress people
but it's not show stopping.
This looks good.
Let's go put in the oven
at 350 degrees for about 25 to 30 minutes.
My brownies are done.
I've let mine cool for a little bit.
You are more than welcome
to eat them right away.
But if you wanna get this perfect square,
let it cool and we'll cut beautifully.
This recipe makes nine perfect squares.
Let's see how these look inside.
Look at that fudgy brownie
with chocolate pockets.
I have my milk, let's try this.
That's a good brownie.
This one's fudgier than the last brownie.
It has a nice chew and it
just melts in your mouth.
This one is really good.
But if you're a chocolate lover,
let's get into the next one.
To get started on our four-hour brownie,
we're gonna brown some butter.
I like to brown my butter in a light pan.
That way I can see the
milk solids browning.
I'm using two sticks of butter
because I want more flavor
in it, I want more fat,
I want it to be decadent.
I want it to show stopping.
When you browning butter,
you always wanna do it on
low heat and constantly stir.
So what you're seeing over
here are the milk solids
and this is what you want to brown.
So we want this to sink to the bottom
and that's what's gonna give
you the deeper, nuttier flavor.
Just don't rush it, take your
time, you don't wanna burn it.
Also, like who does wanna take a break
while they're cooking
and just stir butter.
As soon as you see the brown bits,
you wanna quickly remove it from heat
and put it in a different container
because you don't wanna overcook it.
While our brown butter is still hot,
we're gonna mix it with our sugar
and adding hot butter into
sugar is gonna give your brownie
the beautiful shiny exterior.
In my opinion, this makes
a great dessert right here.
We can just stop now
and call this dessert.
We're gonna set this aside to cool
and we're gonna pull an espresso shot
because we're fancy like that.
I like to add coffee to
my chocolate desserts
'cause it just helps enhance
the chocolate flavor.
But if you don't have an
espresso machine, don't worry,
because you can add regular
coffee, you can add cold brew,
you can even add stout.
It's just a nice way to add
complexity to your dessert.
So I'm gonna show you guys
how I pull my shot at home.
I'm gonna add about 15 grams of espresso.
I'm gonna use my knife and brush it off.
I'm gonna use this little
guy to push the coffee down.
Now I'm gonna attach this to the machine.
Now we pull.
We're looking for only two ounces.
All right, we got two ounces of espresso.
Let's get back to our batter.
So next we can add our egg starch sugar.
I like to add it one at a time.
That way it's well incorporated.
So we're gonna make this for
about two to three minutes
until it gets lighter in color
and this helps us get air into the batter.
Next we're gonna add our espresso,
vegetable oil and vanilla extract.
Our wet ingredients are all ready,
so now we're gonna sift
our dry ingredients.
Now we're gonna sift together our flour,
cocoa powder, and baking powder.
Again, we sift because we're
gonna break up these lumps.
If you don't have a sifter,
you can just get a whisk
and whisk everything very well.
We can add our salt.
If the time commitment makes you scared,
honestly, just give it a try.
I promise this recipe is not that hard.
Now we're gonna add our dry ingredient
into our wet ingredient
and slowly fold it.
And again, I'm turning my
bowl the opposite direction
as a fold in the wet
ingredient into the dry.
It's almost mixed but not quite.
And I'm gonna add my chocolate now
because I wanna stop mixing it
right when everything is incorporated
and I don't wanna over mix it.
In this bowl I have a mixture
of semisweet chocolate
and milk chocolate.
And I'm gonna set some
chunks of chocolate aside
because we're gonna use them as garnish.
And I've broken them
up into different sizes
'cause I just want big
chunks of chocolate,
I want little melty chocolate.
So the milk chocolate
is gonna help balance
the bitterness of the dark chocolate.
Now I'll add my batter into my
8-by-12 prepared baking pan.
Look at all that chocolate.
It was like half upon
the chocolate in here.
Again, we're doing the same thing.
Spread it using an offset spatula.
This is a recipe you wanna
make if you wanna feel fancy
and if your friends
love chocolate, like me.
Last thing we're gonna do is
garnish it with our chocolate.
I want it to look perfect
and rustic at the same time.
You got to find that balance.
And now comes the secret.
We are gonna chill this for two hours.
And you thought you were
gonna work for four hours,
but there's a lot of
downtime in this recipe.
Chilling it for two hours
helps develop the flavors
and gives it a shiny top.
You can even leave it in the
fridge overnight if you want
but we're not that extra.
All right, I'm gonna go
put this in the fridge
and relax for two hours
and I'll be right back.
We're back.
It's been chilling for two hours.
You can already see the difference.
The batter is more firm,
there's shine into it
so it's ready to be baked.
I'm gonna go bake this at 350
for about 35 to 40 minutes.
I know it's been a long time,
but I promise it's worth the wait.
Our four-hour brownies out of the oven.
I'd let it cool for almost an hour
and we're at the finish line.
But before we cut into it, I
wanna sprinkle some sea salt.
I'm gonna cut this into
eight generous pieces.
I'll start at the middle.
She cuts so beautifully.
I can hear the crunch on the top
and feel the gooeyness of the middle.
This is a very generous piece
and anyone who spent four hours
making a brownie deserves it.
Let's check one of the pieces.
Look at the middle.
It looks perfect.
It's dense, it's chocolatey.
I cannot wait to try it.
This is definitely my favorite.
The hints of the salt on the top,
the mixture of the milk chocolate.
Everything, it's just perfectly balanced.
I definitely recommend leaving it
in the fridge for two hours
because it makes a difference.
All right, that's it.
Today we made a four-minute, 40-minute
and a four-hour brownie.
If you have any questions,
leave it in the comment.
I love to hear from you.
Just remember, there's
always time for brownies.
I hope you like this a choco-lot.
Katie's making me say this.
Bye guys.
(light bright upbeat music)